BRIAN:
WELCOME BACK.
THE WHITE HOUSE DOUBLING DOWN ON
THEIR DEFENSE OF THE CDC AFTER
E-MAILS SHOW THE AGENCY TOOK
WORD FOR WORD RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM ONE OF AMERICA’S LARGEST
TEACHERS UNIONS.
OUR NEXT GUEST ARGUES THIS COULD
BE A WINNING ISSUE FOR THE GOP
IN 2022.
HERE TO EXPLAIN, "WALL STREET
JOURNAL" COLUMNIST JASON RILEY.
JASON, IF THE REPUBLICAN STANDS
FOR ANYTHING, IT’S FOR PUTTING
THE KIDS FIRST, AND IT’S FOR
SCHOOL CHOICE.
BOTH THESE THINGS LINE UP TO THE
ACTIONS OF DEMOCRATS.
HOW?
>> WELL, WE KNOW, BRIAN, THAT
UNIONS EXIST FOR THE BENEFIT OF
THEIR MEMBERS WHETHER WE’RE
TALKING ABOUT AUTOWORKERS OR
HOTEL WORKERS OR PRISON GUARDS.
THE DIFFERENCE WITH THE TEACHERS
UNIONS IS THAT FOR YEARS THEY
PRETEND THAT THEIR INTERESTS
LINE UP PERFECTLY WITH THOSE OF
OUR CHILDREN.
AND THE.
PANDEMIC REALLY EXPOSED WHAT A
LIE THAT IS.
YOU KNOW, THE TEACHERS UNIONS
WERE LOOKING OUT FOR THEIR OWN
INTERESTS.
OUR KIDS SUFFERED ACADEMICALLY
FROM THESE LOCKDOWNS, MENTALLY,
PHYSICALLY AND SO FORTH, AND THE
TEACHER UNIONS COULD CARE LESS.
THEY’RE SIMPLY USING IT AS
LEVERAGE TO GET MORE PAY, MORE
BENEFITS AND IS FORTH. -- SO
GOVERNMENT.
AND I THINK -- SO FORTH.
I THINK THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
SHOULD REMIND THE PUBLIC OF IT
CONSTANTLY UNTIL THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS, TAKE THIS MESSAGE
INTO THE COMMUNITY AND EXPLAIN
TO THEM WHY THE TEACHER UNIONS
ARE LOOKING OUT FOR THEMSELVES
AND NOT FOR OUR CHILDREN.
BRIAN: AND, JASON, YOU HAVE THE
E-MAILS AND SAY DON’T JUST SAY
MAKE THESE ANNOUNCEMENTS AND
TALK TO YOUR CON STITCH WENTS,
GO OUT TO PLACES THAT DIDN’T
VOTE FOR YOU.
GO ON BLACK RADIO, BLACK
TELEVISION, MINORITY
COMMUNITIES, EXPLAIN HOW YOU ARE
DIFFERENT AND EXPLAIN WHAT
UNIONS HAVE LEFT YOUR KIDS
BEHIND.
FOR EXAMPLE, TEACHERS UNIONS
RECEIVED -- EXCUSE ME, GAVE IT
$40 MILLION TO THE BIDEN COFFERS
SPECIFICALLY.
AND THIS IS THEIR PAYBACK.
WHERE ARE KIDS IN THIS PICTURE?
REPUBLICANS NEED TO EXPLAIN
THAT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND AS YOU SAID, THEY NEED TO
TAKE THIS MESSAGE DIRECTLY TO
THESE COMMUNITIES.
DON’T GO THROUGH THE ACTIVISTS,
DON’T GO THROUGH THE CIVIL
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE
NAACP AND SO FORTH, GO DIRECTLY
TO THE PEOPLE, GO TO THE
BARBERSHOPS, THE COMMUNITY
CENTERS AND ADVERTISE, YES, OP
ON BLACK RADIO, TELEVISION AND
SOCIAL MEDIA OUTLETS.
TAKE THIS MESSAGE DIRECTLY TO
THE PEOPLE, AND I THINK THEY
WILL FIND A VERY RECEPTIVE
AUDIENCE HERE.
BLACKS AND HISPANICS IN
PARTICULAR FAVOR SCHOOL CHOICE.
THEY LONG HAVE FAVORED SCHOOL
CHOICE IN POLLS.
AND WHAT THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
NEEDS TO EXPLAIN TO THEM IS HOW
SCHOOL CHOICE IS THE BEST
RESPONSE TO WHAT, HOW THE
TEACHERS UNIONS TREATED THEIR
CHILDREN THIS PAST YEAR.
BRIAN: AND, JASON, THAT’S WHAT
VOUCHERS ARE ABOUT.
I’M GOING TO GIVE YOU THIS
VOUCHER.
GO TO THE SCHOOL THAT’S BEST FOR
YOU.
DEMOCRATS SAY, NO, WE’LL TELL
YOU WHERE TO GO.
BY THE WAY, THAT SCHOOL FOR THE
LAST 14 MONTHS HAS BEEN CLOSED.
WHEN YOU GO TO SCHOOL, YOUR
TEACHER’S ON REMOTE.
THAT’S WHAT THEY CHOSE TO DO
OVER -- AND ALLOW YOUR KIDS TO
LOSE MORE GROUND IN THIS
MARKETPLACE.
>> YES, EXACTLY.
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN FOLLOWING THE
SCIENCE.
YOU KNOW, THE IRONY HERE, BRIAN,
IS THAT THE CHILDREN THEMSELVES
HAVE HELD UP WELL AGAINST THE
VIRUS.
THE MOST DAMAGE TO OUR KIDS HAS
BEEN FROM THE SO-CALLED EXPERTS
AND THEIR RIDICULOUS MANDATES.
THEY’VE DONE MUCH MORE HARM TO
THE KIDS THAN THE ACTUAL VIRUS.
AND, AGAIN, REPUBLICANS NEED TO
TAKE THIS MESSAGE DIRECTLY TO
THESE COMMUNITIES.
AND, AGAIN, THIS ISN’T AN
IDENTITY POLITICS ISSUE LIKE THE
LEFT USES TO GO AFTER MINORITY
VOTERS, THIS IS A PRINCIPLED
STANDS ON EDUCATION.
IF YOU -- STANCE ON EDUCATION.
IF YOU WANT TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT VIOLENT CRIME, ABOUT DRUG
ABUSE, TEEN PREGNANCY AND ALL OF
THAT, GET KIDS A DECENT
EDUCATION.
AND THAT’S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
AND THE UNIONS ARE NOT
INTERESTED IN THAT.
THEY ARE INTERESTED IN DOING
WHAT IS BEST FOR THEIR MEMBERS,
AND THAT IS NOT WHAT THESE
FAMILIES NEED.
BRIAN: YEAH.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS
WHERE EVERY -- SOMETIMES YOU
HAVE AN ISSUE AND SAY IT’S GOOD
FOR ME, AND SOMETIMES YOU’RE
ABOUT THAT ISSUE, AND IT
HAPPENED.
AND THAT’S WHAT IT IS.
THIS IS ABOUT SCHOOLS,
EDUCATION, PUTTING KIDS FIRST
OVER UNIONS.
TEACHERS ARE GREAT, THE UNIONS
AREN’T, AND THAT’S WHERE THE
MESSAGE HAS TO GO.
REPUBLICANS HAVE TO STOP TRYING
TO MAXIMIZE THE VOTES THEY HAVE
AND TRY TO GET THE VOTES THEY
DON’T HAVE, AND THAT’S WHAT YOUR